are there any uh mistakes that you feel
like you said earlier that you guys laid
the groundwork for a lot of the new
generation with some of the mistakes you
made what were those mistakes you feel
like you made throughout your music
career that you'd look back on and be
like damn my pride my pride um
being upset getting myself upset I made
a lot of mistakes you know what I'm
saying even with even with you know
mustard you know what I'm saying like me
and mustard ain't talked to years and
that's my brother I always wish him
nothing but success you know what I'm
saying but I can talk about it now
because like I say it's always going to
be my brother I love him and it ain't no
issues what's your guys's original
falling out it wasn't no it wasn't no
falling out I just I just was I just was
in my pride and I'm a man to admit like
when I'm wrong and talking to the wrong
people you know what I'm saying and
people keeping it Stir It Up and I'm
like [ __ ] it and he trying to like have
conversations I'm like nah [ __ ] in a
rinse like bro like why are you so upset
like you know I'm saying this [ __ ] is
business at the end of the day keep that
[ __ ] going and keep that [ __ ] successful
and it [ __ ] up a lot of relationships
dealing with my pride dealing with pride
and and dealing with younger artists
like I I had one take Jay that was then
was my guys then was around me we played
basketball for months and months at a
time great guy and dealing with my pride
like he like big bro what should I do
I'm taking the uh they want a meeting
with me and I'm like [ __ ] you going
beside me trying to do a meeting move
and I just cut him off and like [ __ ]
like that dealing with my pride is like
[ __ ] me up in a lot of situations where
it's like bro why you so why you so
upset like get it together and now that
I'm older I can admit my faults and say
Joe Moses have made a lot of mistakes
dealing with pride
what do you think because a lot of
people it takes like some sort of I mean
I've had I used to you know probably
used to get in the way of a lot of [ __ ]
I used to look at other people and what
they were doing and make it feel some
type of way about what I had going on or
like you said like I'd be like man [ __ ]
them like or I used to really give a
[ __ ] if like
Somebody went to like the other person's
radio show yeah like you know what I
mean but I'm like I don't care about
none of this [ __ ] no more I'm like bro
I'm doing me there's enough money for
everybody but I feel you like was there
something that happened that like really
made you kind of reevaluate that [ __ ]
this is like life is too short losing
these ass uh losing DJ official losing
my father losing my uncle I lost about
since pandemic I lost about 19 people
you know so I'm saying losing people I
don't want to lose my friends like you
know we might not see eye to eye every
day but losing my friends on something
that's not even important I've lost real
people to me to the left and to the
right and I'm looking I'll be like damn
I don't have nobody crazy I don't like I
don't have my father like that's that's
a big thing for me not being having
nobody to talk to sometimes I need
guidance right so I got my my godfather
you you know I call him and make
conversations to him I got my football
friends I got my homies you ever talk
about going to therapy
yeah hey cause look you're the head of
your household no no no no you're a
leader for so many people but who do you
have to no no no that's facts see see
I'm not I'm not afraid of it I'm not I'm
not against it like you know what I'm
saying like I've talked to somebody it
was like maybe Joe you need to go to
therapy you've lost so much and you
bundle this [ __ ] all in it's not it's
not about someone to talk and we have to
stop that narrative too thinking that in
our black homes thinking that you know
that's that's because that's what goes
on the black home we don't need no
[ __ ] therapy you don't need to
go talk to nobody ain't nothing wrong
with your punk ass trust me they said
that's not just black homes why white
trash home as well
that's something that we go through
[ __ ] dad needs therapy that
[ __ ] would never go though nah
I've got so much bottled in bro and
people probably don't understand like I
deal with a lot of issues and a lot of
problems and I sometimes I look up and I
don't have nobody to help me with
nothing have you ever tried mushrooms no
that should might change your language I
might go shoot up
[Music]
misconception nope that's not true
that's not true how are you feeling
therapeutic it's therapeutic it's
therapeutic they actually they're
pushing for uh
psilocybin which is the active
ingredient in mushrooms they're pushing
for psilocybin uh therapy Joe Biden's
trying to get it legalized in the next
two years it's already legal in Portland
like in Portland you go to psychiatrists
and they'll put you like they'll give
you psilocybin in a dose and then work
with you through it's it's trust me do
some research is that if you eat a ton
of anything you're going to trip balls
but like
trust me shrooms is the [ __ ] future
man I've been hearing it it is the
future I've been in a gang of Studio
sessions with some big artists you saw
Meek Mill just tweeted about it yeah but
I've been I've been in some big
producers and big artists with [ __ ]
like hey y'all let's get off these
mushrooms and make these beats and I'm
like
[ __ ] that I ain't doing none of that
[ __ ] I ain't cause I [ __ ] want to
kill all you [ __ ] in this [ __ ]
I can't control I can't even control
weed but but it's a little more
controllable like eating eating weed is
dangerous yeah if you eat weed too much
it's [ __ ]
if you eat too much mushrooms you're
just going to change your life in a
positive way
don't listen to him he has no idea what
he said he's a he's a